if we look at the real clear politics  page where you could see a number of the  recent polls you see that walker is  leading by an average of 1.6 he's plus  four in the emerson poll i just  mentioned walker is plus one in the  recent quinnipiac poll walker is plus  three in the ajc poll  and then back in august of last year in  the democratic leaning pole raphael  warnock was ahead so we don't have that  much polling but none of it looks  particularly good for rafael warnock and  this should genuinely scare us this is  this is one of the most uninformed  people that is running for prominent  office rafael warnock for whatever  you may like or dislike about him  particularly as the incumbent to see him  doing this poorly is very bad